all right well the HTML is a critical
resource and the CSS stylesheet inside
is also going to be render blocking the
image doesn't block the critical
rendering path and this javascript file
at the end is also asynchronous and it
won't block rendering so in total that's
going to be two critical resources the
HTML and the CSS you nailed it
now I didn't ask you about the number of
critical bytes but any idea how you
would go about figuring that out simple
I just need to know the size of the HTML
and the CSS files yep exactly
No what about the critical path length
so let's see the HTML file is one we
have another round trip to get the CSS
and then because this javascript file is
async it's not going to block rendering
so the best case is going to be to as
our critical path length that's right